hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel you might already
know from the title and thumbnail of the
video that today we will discuss the
difference between agile and devops but
before that let's take a step back and
understand what these two are and why
it's important to know these two
methodologies and their differences a
software development methodology is like
a set of instructions or guidelines that
tell the team and individual involved in
the software development how to build
software just like a set of instruction
helps the team make sure they do
everything right a software development
methodology provides a roadmap for a
building software products it outlines
the steps involved in the software
development process from planning and
designing to testing and deployment a
software development methodology is like
a set of best practices that help team
build high quality software products in
a timely and efficient manner and agile
and devops are two of the many software
development methodologies hope this
quick interview production help you
understand why we need to understand the
software development methodologies and
their differences so let's quickly start
with our topic agile versus devops on
that note if you ask me to Advance your
career in the devops field and secure
position in the top tag companies
consider enrolling in the postgraduate
program in devops and intensive training
course that equips you with the top
tools and skills developed in
collaboration with Celtic City yummy
this professional development program
ensures your expertise alliance with
industry standards other Innovative
Blended learning approach combines live
online job certification classes with
interactive Labs providing variable
hands-on experience also accelerate your
career growth with the highly regarded
certified scrum Master certification
gain the necessary Knowledge and Skills
to excel in agile project management
through simply learns comprehensive two
days CSM training course led by
experienced instructors this course
covers all Essentials scrum Frameworks
Concepts preparing youth for the CSM
certification now let's begin with the
topic of agile versus devops Agilent
develops a two distinct approaches in
software development each with its focus
and objectives here is a detailed
comparison between agile and devops
first methodology agile software
development methodology emphasis
flexibility adaptability and iterative
development whereas devops is a cultural
and operational philosophy emphasizing
collaboration and integration between
development and operation teams next we
have objectives agile aims to deliver
high quality software through
incremental development collaboration
and continuous feedback whereas devops
aims to streamline software development
and deployment process enhance
collaboration and Achieve faster time to
Market next let us see the focus of
agile and devops agile focuses on
effective project management closer
customer collaboration and delivering
working software in short iteration
devops focuses on automated eating
process continuous integration and
delivery infrastructure as code and
improving communication and
collaboration between teams next let us
look at the agile and devops tools first
the popular agile tools widely used in
the industry are zeera Trello Azure
devops version 1 and monday.com so this
tools offers a range of features to
support agile practices including
backlog management Sprint planning task
tracking collaboration and Reporting the
popular devops tools widely used in
industry include Jenkins Docker get
ansible and kubernet this tools are top
rated and widely adapted in various
organization to streamline development
and operation process improve efficiency
and enable faster and more Reliable
Software delivery next we have the key
skill set practices first agile
methodologies a solid understanding of
agile principles Frameworks
methodologies and proficiency in agile
practices enable effective Planning
iterative Development and continuous
improvements next iterative and
incremental development agile
professionals should be comfortable
working in short iterations and
delivering incremental value and next we
have adaptability and flexibility agile
professionals should be open to change
and adapt plans and prioritize as needed
some standard agile practices include
scrum can burn and extreme programming
some key skills and knowledge areas
associated with devops are Automation
and scripting so Proficiency in
scripting languages like bash python or
partial is essential for automating
routine tasks infrastructure
provisioning and deployment process next
CI CD pipelines setting up and managing
continuous integration and deployment
pipelines and then we have configuration
management managing and automating the
configuration of systems and
applications and some of key skills and
knowledge area associated with devops
are infrastructure as code Cloud
platforms monitoring and logging and
many more and next let's have a look at
the benefits of agile and devops agile
enables faster response to change
improved customer satisfaction and early
and frequent delivery of working
software whereas devops facilitates
faster software delivery improved
quality through automating and testing
increased efficiency and better
alignment between development and
operation teams and next let's have a
look at some of the popular career
opportunities in agile and devops so in
agile include the scrum Master agile
coach product owner agile project
manager and many more and some popular
career opportunities in devops include
devops engineer site reliability
engineer automation engineer Cloud
engineer and many more next let's have a
look at this salaries the average salary
for an agile software engineer in the
United States is around 175 000 annually
in India it is 9 lakh per annum the
average salary for a devops engineer in
the United States is around 104 000
annually in India at a 7 lakhs per annum
and some notable companies known for
focusing on agile and frequently hiring
in this area are Spotify Amazon Google
IBM Microsoft and many more some
companies are actively hiring and known
for their prominency in devops include
Cisco Amazon Google Infosys Microsoft
and many more now that you know the
agile and devops skills and objectives
this simply learns postgraduate program
in devops will equip you with all the
necessary skills including devops
methodology continuous integration
continuous delivery deployment
automation Cloud platforms and many more
along with the skills it also covers
tools such as terraform mavin ansible
zenkins kubernetes Docker and many more
check out the course Link in the
description for more details now let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced new success in
their career I started my It Journey
with Accenture three years ago I joined
there as a cloud architect there I
worked with AWS at Azure Technologies I
was anyway looking for higher paying job
and devops seem the right career choice
so I decided to go with the postgraduate
program in devops in collaboration with
Caltech ctme course was divided into
modules
and we had assignments I was really
impressed by how many job interviews I
landed after I added a certification to
my portfolio and now I am earning 40
more than my previous job didn't only
boost my career but also my confidence
but
the box tutorial if you like this video
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss any updates
from Simply love and if you need any
help opting for this courses please let
us know in the comment section below we
will get back to you as soon as possible
until next time thank you and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here